les morlaisiens sont au rendez vous pour
fêter les 50 ans de la ville des bribes
de photographies retracent l'histoire de
maurepas sur la plage à cri bout du
chantier de la poste commencé en 1972 à
l'école de la marnière des souvenirs
rejaillissent c'est avec une pointe
d'émotion et beaucoup dé fierté que le
maire et goerig d'aristide ouvre
l'événement temps et je suis mort
patients de naissance voilà j'aime ma
ville et voilà je je trouve que son
urbanisme sa conception est une très
bonne chose est une très belle réussite
et en plus de pouvoir accueillir à ce
50e anniversaire l'architecte ne mord
pas le fils du promoteur monsieur riboud
et le sculpteur pour la première fois
réunis sont un événement comme celui là
voilà c'est un honneur pour moi tout est
pensé pour que chacun fait nous faut un
soleil de plomb les enfants profitent
des jouets gonflables installées pour
l'occasion
pendant que les adultes eux échangent
autour des retards tout en ostalgie
salon rappelle tous les souvenirs du
début puisque je suis là depuis 1970 69
donc j'ai vu toute l'évolution de
des différents sites qui sont indiqués
sur le sur ces photos quoi moi c'est un
peu bizarre parce que j'ai vu mon
ancienne école et
elle a beaucoup changé il y avait des
jeux que je connaissais pas des endroits
où je vais tous les jours
quelque chose il faut sauver pakistan
comme ça la journée prend fin et se
termine sur une dernière note de musique
un événement qui sera pour sûr un
souvenir de plus pour les norvégiens